Le problème, c'est qu'on a beaucoup de données qualitatives
tout simplement incompréhensibles.
La première fois que vous avez écouté votre chanson préférée,
que faisiez-vous ?
Qu'avez-vous ressenti ?
Vous avez eu la chair de poule ?
Ou vous étiez à fond ?
Difficile à décrire, non ?
Des parties de nous ont l'air si simples,
mais une complexité inouïe se cache sous la surface.
Traduire cette complexité à des machines
sera une des avancées majeures de notre temps.
Je ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse répondre à ces questions existentielles
uniquement par du code binaire.
Au laboratoire, la création artistique
est ma façon de concevoir de meilleures expériences
pour les technologies de pointe.
L'art me sert de catalyseur
pour renforcer au maximum la dimension humaine comprise par les ordinateurs.
À travers l'art, on aborde des questions très difficiles,
comme ce que veut vraiment dire « ressentir ».
Comment s'investir et savoir être là pour les autres.
Et comment l'intuition influence notre façon d'interagir.
Prenons par exemple l'émotion humaine.
Actuellement, les ordinateurs peuvent comprendre les plus basiques
comme la joie, la tristesse, la colère, la peur et le dégoût,
en convertissant mathématiquement ces traits caractéristiques.
Mais qu'en est-il des émotions plus complexes ?
Ces émotions
qu'on a du mal à décrire à quelqu'un d'autre.
Comme la nostalgie.
Pour l'étudier, j'ai créé une œuvre d'art, une expérience,
qui demande aux gens de partager un souvenir.
J'ai fait équipe avec des experts en mégadonnées
pour comprendre comment saisir une émotion aussi subjective
et la convertir en quelque chose de précis pour les mathématiques.
On a donc créé une matrice de la nostalgie
et c'est le cœur de cette installation.
Pour ce faire, l'installation demande de raconter une histoire,
l'ordinateur analyse ensuite les émotions les plus simples.
Il vérifie la tendance à utiliser les verbes au passé
et cherche les mots souvent associés à la nostalgie,
comme « maison », « enfance » et « le passé ».
Puis une matrice de nostalgie est créée,
indiquant le degré de nostalgie de l'histoire.
La matrice agit sur ces sculptures lumineuses
qui incarnent chaque contribution.
Plus le score est élevé, plus la lumière est rose.
C'est comme voir la vie en rose.
Quand on voit son score
et sa représentation artistique,
on est parfois d'accord, mais pas toujours.
C'est comme si l’œuvre d'art comprenait ce qu'on ressent.
Mais, d'autres fois, c'est perturbant,
on a l'impression de ne pas avoir été du tout compris.
Cette œuvre d'art sert à montrer
que, si on a du mal à expliquer nos émotions les uns aux autres,
comment apprendre à un ordinateur à les comprendre ?
Même les dimensions les plus objectives de l'homme sont dures à décrire.
Comme la conversation.
Avez-vous déjà brisé les étapes dans une conversation ?
Imaginez que vous êtes assis avec un ami à un café
parlant de tout et de rien.
Comment savoir quand prendre un tournant ?
Comment savoir quand changer de sujet ?
Et même comment savoir de quels sujets parler ?
La plupart de nous n'y pense pas vraiment,
c'est comme une seconde nature.
Quand on rencontre quelqu'un, on en apprend plus sur ses passions
et on apprend de quels sujets on peut parler.
Mais quand il faut enseigner à l'IA comment interagir avec les gens,
on doit lui expliquer étape par étape.
Actuellement, c'est encore trop inadapté.
Si vous avez déjà essayé de parler avec Alexa, Siri ou l'Assistant Google,
vous remarquerez que leurs réponses paraissent désincarnées.
Avez-vous déjà été agacé
quand ils n'ont pas compris ce que vous disiez
et que vous avez dû reformuler 20 fois votre requête pour écouter une chanson.
Il faut reconnaître aux designers
qu'une communication réaliste est très complexe.
Il y a une branche entière de la sociologie,
l'analyse conversationnelle,
qui cherche à modéliser différents types de conversations.
Comme le service client, le conseil, l'enseignement, etc.
J'ai travaillé au laboratoire avec un analyste conversationnel
pour aider nos systèmes d'IA à discuter d'une façon qui semble plus humaine.
Ainsi, en interagissant avec un chatbot sur son portable
ou avec un système vocal en voiture,
l'échange semblera un peu plus humain, moins froid et désincarné.
J'ai créé une œuvre d'art
qui souligne les maladresses d'expression des robots
pour aider les designers à comprendre
pourquoi ils ne parlent pas encore comme des humains et ce qu'on peut y faire.
Elle s'appelle Bot to Bot,
c'est l'interaction de deux systèmes conversationnels
qui est exposée au public.
Au final, on arrive au résultat
d'une tentative d'imiter une discussion,
sans y parvenir.
Soit ça fonctionne, soit on reste
dans des sortes de spirales de malentendus.
Si la conversation d'une machine à l'autre peut avoir du sens,
grammaticalement et dans la forme,
elle paraît toujours froide et robotique.
Même en remplissant tous les critères, le dialogue manque d'âme
et de ces traits uniques qui font ce que nous sommes.
Même en étant grammaticalement correct
et en utilisant les hashtags et les emojis appropriés,
le dialogue finit par sembler mécanique et un peu sinistre.
On appelle ça la vallée mystérieuse.
L'élément sinistre d'une technologie
qui est proche de l'humain, mais pas complètement.
Et mon œuvre va devenir
une façon de tester l'humanité d'une conversation
et les éléments perdus dans la traduction.
D'autres choses sont aussi perdues dans la traduction,
comme l'intuition humaine.
Actuellement, les ordinateurs sont plus autonomes.
Ils peuvent nous rendre des services,
comme changer la température de la maison selon nos préférences
ou même aider à conduire sur une autoroute.
Mais vous et moi faisons certaines choses en personne
qui sont très difficiles à traduire à une IA.
Pensez à votre dernière rencontre avec un ancien camarade de classe ou collègue.
Vous êtes-vous embrassés ou serré la main ?
Vous n'avez pas hésité un instant
car vous avez tellement passé de moments ensemble
que vous savez quoi faire.
En tant qu'artiste, je sens qu'atteindre l'intuition de quelqu'un,
son savoir inconscient,
nous aide à créer des choses extraordinaires.
Des grandes idées, depuis cet abstrait, ce lieu chaotique dans notre conscience
où culminent toutes nos expériences.
Pour créer un lien avec les ordinateurs
et qu'ils amplifient nos capacités créatives,
je pense qu'il faudra réfléchir à comment rendre les ordinateurs plus intuitifs.
J'ai donc voulu comprendre comment l'intuition humaine
pourrait être traduite sans filtre à une intelligence artificielle.
Et j'ai créé une œuvre qui explore l'intuition informatique
dans l'espace physique.
Cette œuvre s'appelle Wayfinding,
elle est formée d'un compas symbolique avec quatre sculptures cinétiques.
Chacune représente une direction :
nord, est, sud et ouest.
Des capteurs sont placés au dessus de chaque sculpture
pour mesurer la distance entre elle et vous.
Les données collectées
vont changer le mouvement des sculptures
et la direction du compas.
L'installation ne fonctionne pas comme un capteur de porte automatique
qui s'ouvre juste en marchant devant elle.
Votre contribution n'est qu'une partie de sa collection d'expériences vécues.
Toutes ces expériences influencent la façon dont l’œuvre d'art bouge.
Donc quand on marche devant elle,
elle se met à utiliser tous les données
emmagasinées pendant toute l'exposition –
ou son intuition –
pour nous répondre mécaniquement en utilisant ce qu'elle appris des autres.
Au final, les participants
commencent à comprendre le niveau de détail nécessaire
afin de gérer les attentes
tant des humains que des machines.
On peut presque voir notre intuition interprétée sur l'ordinateur,
représentant toutes les données traitées par notre œil et notre cerveau.
J'espère que ce type d'art
nous aidera à penser différemment l'intuition
et comment l'intégrer à l'IA dans le futur.
Voici quelques exemples de mon utilisation de l'art pour nourrir mon travail
de designer et de chercheur en intelligence artificielle.
Je le vois comme une méthode clé pour faire progresser l'innovation.
Car, actuellement, il y a beaucoup d'opinions extrêmes sur l'IA.
Les blockbusters la présentent en force de destruction
alors que les publicités l'encensent comme le sauveur,
à même de résoudre des problèmes très complexes dans le monde.
Mais quelles que soient nos opinions,
il est dur de contester qu'on vit dans un monde
qui devient de plus en plus numérique à chaque seconde.
Nos vies tournent autour de nos appareils, des applications intelligentes, etc.
Et je ne crois pas que ça va s'arrêter de sitôt.
Je cherche donc à intégrer plus d'humanité dès le départ.
J'ai le pressentiment qu'amener l'art
dans la recherche en intelligence artificielle
est une façon d'y arriver.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)